many sci-fi fans have long hoped for a
version of dune that would do greater
visual and narrative justice to frank
herbert's work now director denis
villeneuve has been drafted to bring it
to the big screen here's everything we
know about the 2021 adaptation of doom
so far
the road to making a new cinematic
version of dune was lengthy even before
the current roster of talent signed on
for the film director denis villeneuve
who'd long hoped to helm a new
adaptation of the novel signed on to
make the film in 2017. however it wasn't
until two years later that the project
actually landed a 2020 release date then
the covet 19 pandemic hit making a 2020
release for dune very unlikely and
leaving warner brothers to make some new
moves in october of 2020 warner brothers
announced that the film would shift to
october 1st 2021 then in december the
studio dropped some even bigger news its
entire 2021 film slate including doom
would also simultaneously premiere on
the hbo max streaming service giving
viewers a chance to watch the film at
home without waiting
it's time any dune adaptation faces a
monumental challenge in assembling a
cast to phil herbert's universe it
starts with finding the perfect actors
to stand in the center of it all as the
etredes family in 2018 oscar nominee
timothy chalamet joined the film as paul
atreides making dune his first
blockbuster role shortly after reports
of chalamet's involvement started
circulating rebecca ferguson joined the
film as paul's mother the beni jesuit
woman lady jessica she first begins
teaching him the gifts that will later
manifest as messianic abilities with the
two most prominent members of house of
tradies in place it was time for the
film to cast duke leto atreides this is
paul's father who brings his family to
arrakis to take over leadership of the
planet and finds only trouble in early
2019 it was revealed that duke ledo
would be played by oscar isaac who adds
another major sci-fi franchise to his
resume just a few years after joining
the star wars galaxy these three actors
form the core family unit that is house
of trades but they're far from the only
major stars in the film
dune is an epic novel spanning several
years and featuring two major royal
houses atreides and harkenin who battle
each other for supremacy on the planet
one that also includes its own native
race the fremen that means a massive
cast needed to be assembled to make the
film work because this is a denis
villeneuve film adaptation of one of the
most beloved genre novels ever a-list
actors have lined up to make the
supporting cast for dune a truly
all-star ensemble among the stars
assembled to round out the film's cast
are stellan skarsgard jason momoa javier
bardem zendaya josh brolin david
dasmalchen dave bautista and charlotte
rambling it's an exciting diverse
roundup of some of the most acclaimed
actors working right now in both action
blockbusters and prestige dramas it's
exactly the right blend for herbert's
sprawling space opera of warring
dynasties
dune is one of the most celebrated and
influential science fiction novels ever
written first published in 1965 frank
herbert's novel is set amid a future
civilization built on a kind of
interplanetary feudal system there's a
central government led by an emperor and
various planets are controlled by his
vassals which take the title of baron or
duke the main action of dune takes place
on the planet arrakis it's one of the
most important fiefdoms in the empire
because its vast deserts contain the
spice an addictive and valuable
substance the novel follows the atreides
family as they are given control of
arrakis by the emperor only to find that
a vast plot to overthrow them is already
underway amid these political struggles
duke lido's atreides young son paul
begins to manifest superhuman abilities
that make him a messiah figure among the
local fremont a rebellion begins and
paul's abilities make him into a leader
fit to challenge the emperor himself
hello duke of course herbert's novel is
much more complicated than that and
after dune he just kept going herbert
himself wrote five sequels to the novel
and concluded his series with chapter
house dune in 1985 but the story didn't
end there herbert's son brian picked up
the torch from his father and with
novelist kevin j anderson has published
more than a dozen more dune books many
of them prequels to the original novel
the earliest attempts to adapt dune for
the screen kicked off just a few years
after the novel was published in the
mid-1970s director alejandro jorowski
launched a tremendously ambitious effort
to bring the novel to the screen the
project involved everyone from orson
welles to salvador dali to pink floyd
jodorowsky eventually abandoned the
project when the financing for the film
could not be fully realized but his
efforts were later chronicled in the
2013 documentary dodorowski's doom the
post star wars era improved the fortunes
of dune as a movie so in 1984 a big
screen version helmed by director david
lynch was finally released starring kyle
mclaughlin as paula tradies although it
has since become a cult film doom was a
box office flop and earned negative
reviews lynch not yet the household name
he would be after twin peaks was
frustrated by a lack of creative control
and eventually disowned his dune
altogether a longer and more faithful
adaptation of herbert's novel arrived on
the small screen in 2000 as frank
herbert's dune it's a tv miniseries
written by john harrison that aired in
three two hour installments on the
sci-fi channel it was successful enough
that a sequel frank herbert's children
of dune followed in 2003 and adapted the
next two novels in herbert's series
attempts to bring dune back to the big
screen kicked into gear in 2008 when
paramount's pictures announced peter
berg would direct a new adaptation that
effort eventually stalled and in 2016
legendary pictures announced that they
had landed the film and tv rights for
doom
soon after legendary's announcement that
they would be adapting dune for the
screen again reports began to circulate
that director denivel new was the
studio's choice to direct the new film
version villeneuve's involvement was
confirmed by brian herbert in 2017 after
he dazzled audiences with a rival but
before blade runner 2049 arrived in
theaters to critical acclaim thanks to
those two films in particular villeneuve
is one of the most important voices in
science fiction cinema right now he's a
lifelong dune fan who called the chance
to adapt the book the project of his
life but he made it clear that he
wouldn't be relying on the lynch film
version at all villeneuve said i mean
david lynch is one of the best
filmmakers alive i have massive respect
for him but when i saw his adaptation i
was impressed but it was not what i had
dreamed of so i'm trying to make the
adaptation of my dreams it will not have
any link with the david lynch movie i'm
going back to the book and going to the
images that came out when i read it
frank herbert's original novel is not
the longest genre epic you're likely to
find on the shelves at your local
bookstores but it is among the most
dense dune is a book absolutely packed
with plot covering dozens of characters
multiple groups and cultures and a vast
mythology some of which is only hinted
at in the first novel it's the kind of
book so full of detail that it needs an
appendix at the back so you can look up
various invented terms for more clarity
that means adapting the book to the
screen is hard particularly when you're
working within the constraints of a
big-budget film these days that pretty
much demands you weigh in with a runtime
of three hours or less even with that in
mind though adapting dune as one three
hour story is a daunting prospect that's
defeated filmmakers in the past so for
vilnius film version the solution was
obvious don't try to make dune one film
vilnev made it clear that he was setting
a goal of two films for dune in the
summer of 2018 brian herbert confirmed
that the screenplay for the new film
would adapt approximately half of the
first novel in the series it's not clear
how far approximately half will take us
but the novel does include a time jump
to allow paula tradies to age a bit at
one point so it's possible the first
film will leave off there
brian herbert confirmed in 2018 that
villeneuve's desire to split dune into
two films had come to fruition and that
the film we'd see first would only adapt
half the novel this was reaffirmed in
the spring of 2019 by legendary picture
ceo joshua grodd who added a little
context as to why the split happened he
shared there's a backstory that was
hinted at in some of the books that we
expanded also when you read the book
there's a logical place to stop the
movie before the book is over there's
one really interesting wrinkle in all of
this though yes dune will be split into
two films but it's not like the lord of
the rings peter jackson shot all of
those movies back to back but vilnev is
not making one dune film right after the
other instead legendary seems to be
waiting to see how the first film fares
before launching into production on a
sequel this adds intrigue to what
villeneuve said when he first discussed
his two movie plan he said doom will
probably take two years to make the goal
is to make two films maybe more so far
the only adaptation we've gotten beyond
herbert's first novel is the children of
dune miniseries however if villeneuve
has his way we could one day see a film
version of other books
after years of anticipation the first
official trailer for dune arrived in
september of 2020. this was back when
warner brothers was still holding out
hope that the film might make it into
theaters that december that of course
didn't happen but the trailer still
managed to capture the hearts and
imaginations of fans raising the
anticipation level for the film more
than a year before its eventual release
the first trailer is much more of a
teaser than a full plot breakdown it
spends much of its time with paula
tradies as he grapples with visions of
what might happen to him and his family
as they head for the desert planet of
arrakis we see him tested tormented and
doing his best to be strong even as the
dangers of the planet become apparent
the trailer is of course packed with
dazzling visuals leading up to the
reveal of a sand worm at the end the
second official trailer released in
summer of 2021 digs more heavily into
the plot and the supporting cast of the
film and pays particular attention to
chani the fremen girl paul eventually
falls in love with in this trailer we
get a much better sense of the plot paul
begins to realize not only that his
family is in grave danger from the evil
hearkenings but that he himself might
not actually be the person to lead house
treaties into the future it's a much
fuller view of the film one that allows
us to see more of the internal dynamics
of the ensemble as well as some great
action sequences
get everything with guns off the ground
go
not all were happy when warner media
announced dune would simultaneously
premiere in theaters and on the hbo max
streaming service including dune
director denis villeneuve in a statement
released a variety at the time
villeneuve blasted warner's parent
company at t he explains that he learned
about the release plans quote in the
news like everyone else he wrote with
this decision a t has hijacked one of
the most respectable and important
studios in film history there is
absolutely no love for cinema nor for
the audience here though villeneuve was
not the only critic of the release
strategy he has remained among the
loudest in an august 2021 interview with
total film he called the move ridiculous
and regarding watching dune on a home tv
said it's like driving a speedboat in
your bathtub
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
upcoming movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]